من الجيد منح الناس إجازة ليوم واحد ،
نعم ، لم يكن الأمر كذلك ، لقد أثرت عليّ ،
كنا نحاول الحصول على بعض المعلومات
حول الشركة ولم أستطع الوصول إلى هناك
لأنني لم أتمكن من الدخول إلى facebook ،
نعم إنه كذلك لأنه  بدون فيسبوك ،
لا يمكنني التواصل مع عائلتي
من
أطلس في إفريقيا
، ونعم ، لست قادرًا على التواصل مع
الأصدقاء
والعائلة ، ولم يؤثر علي كثيرًا ، فأنا أستخدمه فقط
عندما لا يمكنني الحصول على أشخاص  في رسالة
نصية أو عندما أتحدث إلى محادثة العائلة ،
لذا لم أكن أدرك في الواقع
أنه كان خارجًا حتى قبل دقيقتين ،
لذا أود أن أقول لا ليس
لهذا السبب
حقًا وجدت نفسي أعمل بجد اليوم
لأنني لم أكن مشتتًا  من خلال
الهراء الذي أراه على facebook كل
يوم ، أعتقد أنه أثر علي لأنني
أكثر إنتاجية اليوم
، لم يعمل facebook طوال اليوم
، فلن يتم تحديثه ، إنه غير قابل للاستخدام